tras la muerte del ex presidente carlos
saúl menen este domingo por la mañana el
presidente argentino alberto fernández
decretó tres días de duelo nacional
además se dispuso que el velatorio
tuviera lugar en el salón azul principal
salón del congreso de la nación allí
donde me fuera senador desde el año 2005
luego el lunes según informó su hija a
su límite
los restos serán trasladados a un
cementerio islámico en las afueras de la
ciudad allí están los restos del hijo
del ex presidente de carlitos menem
junior quien murió en un accidente de
helicóptero en el año 1995 carlitos
menem era musulmán su padre había nacido
musulmán y se había convertido al
catolicismo la noticia de la muerte de
carlos menen tras una larga
convalecencia estado internado desde
diciembre de 2020 llegó a todo el arco
político del país que reaccionó en
general con saludos y muestras de
respeto incluso afecto mucha de esta
gente que hoy está en el centro de la
escena política argentina comenzó o
consolidó su carrera durante el gobierno
de carlos menem entre 1989 y 1990
un gobierno y un personaje que los
volúmenes muy polémicos que ha generado
muchos contrastes a lo largo de su vida
y muchas discusiones sobre las
decisiones que tomó cuando estuvo al
frente de las riendas del país pero un
personaje que sin lugar a dudas ha
dejado su marca en la historia en la
historia política del argentino